blacklight sénateurs est il incompatible
avec alive matters ça c'est la grosse
question évidemment toutes les vicomtes
cela va de soi mais dans un pays comme
les etats unis
les choses n'ont pas toujours été aussi
évidente la vie des autochtones ne
comptait pas beaucoup ils ont été
souvent génocide et la vie des noirs ne
comptait pas beaucoup ils ont souvent
été réduits en esclavage de canton dit
black light mature c'est pour réagir à
une situation dans laquelle évidence
n'était pas évidente
simplement il ya beaucoup de gens
conservateurs pour ne pas dire
franchement raciste qui ne veulent pas
qu'on mette l'accent sur l'injustice sur
les victimes et qui veulent dieu non non
on va noyer le poisson toutes les vies
compter sur toutes les vicomtes mais le
problème c'est que pendant longtemps ce
n'était pas le cas et même encore
aujourd'hui il ya eu des génocides et
crimes contre l'humanité
et pas contre les blancs que je sache
c'est en général plutôt des blancs qui
faisait des crimes contre l'humanité
contre les autochtones ou contre les
noirs en france on pourrait faire la
même démonstration dont bien sûr toutes
les vicomtes mais en apparence toutes
les villes ne comptait pas donc c'est
pour cela qu'il n'y important de
réaffirmer cette valeur toutes les
vicomtes je vois même pas pourquoi il y
à un débat aux états unis contre cette
formule des menaces matters
j'ai envie de dire évidemment mais ça
n'était pas évident là est le problème
au moment